في السنوات الاخيره كانت موجه من
التكنولوجيا تحاول التنبؤ بشكل افضل
بالكوارث مثل الفيضانات وامواج تسونامي
والزلازل ترتبط هذه الموجه بشكل كبير
بالذكاء الاصطناعي يستخدم الباحثون
خوارزميات التعلم العميق لغربله ضوضاء
المدينه بحيث يمكن جمع بيانات الزلازل
بشكل افضل اي انها تعتمد على تحليل جميع
الموجات الصوتيه والزلزاليه على عكس
التقنيات السابقه التي تقوم بانتقاء اصوات
معينه لتسجيلها وتحليلها وجد الباحثون ان
الموجات الصوتيه التي تصدر اثناء الانزلاق
البطيء للصفائح الارضيه ترتبط بشكل دقيق
بحاله الضغط الذي تتعرض له هذه الصفائح
وبالزمن المتبقي قبل تصدعها وحدوث الزلزال
يقول الباحثون ان هذه الطريقه يمكنها
الزمن المتبقي لحدوث الزلزال مع هامش خطا
لا يتجاوز 10% لكن هذا الهامش يتقلص الى
اثنين ونصف في المئه مع اقتراب لحظه حدوث
الزلزال
[موسيقى]
يعني دخل الذكاء الاصطناعي حتى على خط
الزلازل هذه المره سنتحدث مع اهل الاختصاص
في هذا الموضوع من عمان رائد سمور خبير
امن المعلومات اهلا بك استاذ رائد معنا في
صباح العربيه وفي هذه التغطيه المتعلقه
بالزلازل طيب اليوم عندما نسال اهل
الاختصاص والخبراء في الزلازل هل يمكن
التنبؤ في الزلازل سمعنا اكثر من اجابه
وكانه في شبه اجماع يا استاذ رائد انه
تقريبا لا يمكن التنبؤ بالشكل الدقيق
وبالموعد والمده الزمنيه ياتي الان الذكاء
الاصطناعي ويقول لنا عكس ذلك بانه يمكن
التنبؤ هل فعلا يمكن التنبؤ بالاساس
نعم اول شيء صباح الخير
ندعو للسلامه ولكل الجرحى ولكل المصابين
وتعازينا لكل اللي توفوا
العموم انا دائما انتصر للعلم ودائما
انحاز الى التقنيات وانا اقول يعني واخالف
رايي من يقول انه في استحاله لكن لكن
الموضوع الموضوع ليس سهلا الحقيقه نعم في
امكانيه للتدخل الذكاء الاصطناعي في مثل
هذه الحالات وتوقع حدوث زلازل لكن هذه
المساله تحتاج الى جهد اممي ولا تحتاج الى
جهد يعني مؤسسي واحد في دوله واحده لانه
لانه طبيعه الزلازل بشكل عام مرتبطه في
بعضها بتصير في هزي مثلا في منطقه جغرافيه
معينه بصير فيه الها ارتداد في منطقه
جغرافيه مختلفه تماما فعمليا هذه المساله
تحتاج الى جهد كبير جدا وتحتاج ايضا الى
الانسان وليس فقط الى الذكاء الاصطناعي
بشكل عام لانه
بدها تعمل هذه التقنيه الكشف عمليا كيف
بدنا مجسات اول اشي بدنا قرون استشعار
مجسات خاصه في المناطق النشطه في الزلازل
هذه الزلازل يعني مش خبير في الزلازل لكن
قرات خلال الساعات الماضيه عن هذا الموضوع
انه عمليا في في بصير في احتكاك في السطح
الصخري لمنطقه معينه هذا يحدث امواج صوتيه
هم يعتمدوا على الامواج الصوتيه وتحليل
هذه الامواج وضخامه هذه الامواج ومتى يعني
تنتقل من من مستوى الى مستوى اكبر معناته
هناك تحرك زلزالي معناه في هناك نوع من
انواع يعني التوقع لحدوث زلزال لكن هذه
تحتاج الى مجسات تحتاج الى قرون استشعار
تحتاج الى جهد بشري ايضا في تحليل الداتا
وتعليم هذه الماكينات او هذه الروبوتات
نعلمها اليات التوقع
وضخ المعلومات كل مكان
المعلومات لهذه
الذكاء الاصطناعي صحيح ودقيق مئه في المئه
كلما كانت النتائج صحيحه ودقيقه وانا
اعتقد انه يعني هذا هذا مجهود يجب ان يكون
على مستوى الامم المتحده ولا يكون على
مستوى الدوله واحده هذا مجهود اممي لابد
وان تتضافر الجهود اليه حتى نصل الى مثل
هذه المرحله حتى نتجنب هذه الكوارث طيب بس
استاذ رائد يعني هل يمكن للذكاء الاصطناعي
مثلا ان يحلل تاريخيا ما حصل سابقا يربط
العوامل القديمه بالمعطيات الحاليه وان
يستخلص نتيجه ما قد يمكن تفادي ما يمكن
انقاذه من اي زلزال قد يحصل مستقبلا
نعم شريط التغذيه المعلومات لهذا الذكاء
الاصطناعي الذكاء الاصطناعي امتى تجيب
المعلومات تجيبها في في انسان بشري بده
يعطيه هذه المعلومات وبالتالي هو يصبح
بتجميع هذه المعلومات ويصبح يتعلم كيف
يتعامل مع هذه المعلومات وبالتالي يخرج
بنتائج نعم من الممكن لكن شريطه تغذيه هذا
الذكاء الاصطناعي بالمعلومات اللازمه
الصحيحه من اجل ان يتعلم الالف باء بموضوع
الزلازل هذا هذا الشيء واقع وسوف نعيش
واقع
قبلنا او لم نقبل هذا الهولندي لعمليه
وتوقع قبل ثلاث ايام من حدوث الزلزال هذا
ما اشتغل هيك في التنجيم ما جاب فنجان
وقرار بالفنجان هذا قرا
بمواضيع وبتحليل معلومات واشتغل عليها
وبالتالي كانت نتائج مذهله ونتائج يعني
صائبه الحقيقه فهذا هذا بيعطينا هذا هذا
اول الخيط يجب ان نمسك فيه يعني بهذه المس
منها من هذا الهولندي اللي البروفيسور
يعني على كل حال يا استاذ رائد حاولنا
شخصيا انه نتواصل معه لكن حتى الان
بانتظار الرد الى نتمنى ذلك والله نشكرك
جزيل الشكر من اعمال رائد سمور خبير امن
المعلومات شكرا لك